يعد ميدان تقسيم واحدا من ابرز المناطق
السياحيه في اسطنبول ويقع في الجانب
الاوروبي من المدينه الميدان يمثل مركز
اسطنبول الحديثه وتاسس عام
1928 من القرن الماضي في الذكرى الخامسه
لاعلان لجمهوريه يتفرعون من الساحه جاده
او شارع الاستقلال وهو شارع تسوق طويل
للمشاه يصل طوله الى كيلو و300 متر عند
الساعه الرابعه و20 دقيقه مساءا بالتوقيت
المحلي وقعا في جارا في الشارع المزدحم
بالمره والمتسوقين الشرطه التركيه فرضت
فوقا امنيا في مكان التفجير واخلت منطقه
تقسيم المجاوره تحسبا الانفجار اخر وسائل
اعلام محليه تحدثت عن انتشار امني مكثف في
منطقه تقسيم وشارع الاستقلال في وقت
تتواصلوا فيها التحقيقات لمعرفه تفاصيل
التفجيره اكثر مره تعرض شارع الاستقلال
لسلسله من التفجيرات القاتله التي تبناها
تنظيم داعش خاصه عام 2015 و 2016 واسفرت
حينها عن سقوط عشرات القتل والجرحى من
جهته قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ان امراه ضالعه بهجوم تقسيم في اسطنبول
مشيرا الى ان التحقيقات ما زالت جاريه
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي اكد اردوغان ان الهجوم
نفذ بقنبله
كان هناك تفجير في شارع الاستقلال ووقع
قتله وجرحى اتمنى شفاء العاجل لهم وتم نقل
الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين على
التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب لم يصل لمبتغاه والعناصر التي
تحاول النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تحقق
طموحها وسينال المجرمون عقابهم